8 news now breaking news alert
we'll have those stories coming up here
in just a couple of minutes but first we
do have some breaking news to get to
court records now show that three more
people are charged along with alvin
kamara for a beating outside of a
nightclub on pro bowl weekend christian
gossip is joining us in the newsroom
with more on this breaking story kristen
that's right guys well saints running
back alvin kamara was arrested and
charged after the game now three more
men face charges in the case now they
all face two charges conspiracy to
commit battery and battery resulting in
substantial bodily
now we are told that the three others
charged are darren christopher young
christopher lamont and piercy ahmad
harris now there is a cornerback on the
kansas city chiefs with the same name
and of course we're talking about
christopher lamont's court records show
a warrant for le mans and that young and
harris have been arrested a police
report says kamara punched darnell
greens outside of dre's eight times then
the others stomped on him at least 16
times green was hospitalized and had a
fracture
on his right eye camaro was arrested
after he played in the pro bowl and has
since posted bail now kamara has not
faced any disciplinary action on behalf
of the nfl and his attorneys say his
reported actions are not consistent with
his prior actions they have court
appearance scheduled in march guys
christian thanks for that